comment distinguer les soignants dé
soigner dans un établissement aussi
atypique
installé au coeur de la forêt de sologne
vingt ans après ce reportage
le scénariste aurélien ducoudray et son
compère jeff pourquier déambulent aussi
pour faire une bande dessinée un voyage
initiatique en immersion totale sur deux
ans on pensait être de petite souris
consacré voilà observer on peut faire
des croquis puis finalement l'état
impliqués tout de suite pour la montée
cet atelier bd et le retour étaient
formidables parce qu'en fait du coup ils
sont mis aussi à l'heure de la bd il ya
la bd partout j'avais fait des
affichages euros pour le boîtier qui à
la salle commune
c'était génial quand on pense en t il
était heureux comme nous cette rencontre
des expériences fortes des lieux chargés
d'histoire tout ça transparaît dans ses
111 pages en 1956 quand claude jean
girard créé la chesnaie on parlait alors
d'humaniser la folie c'est beaucoup plus
dur aujourd'hui le moment de la
rédaction du scénario le le salon juste
était d'arriver à compresser tous acquis
sans que ça soit indigeste
du coup il fallait un peu compris mais
les journées compris même prix que les
autres y compris mais un petit l'outil
donc je sais pas ce qui était
intéressant c'est que jeff était là tout
le temps donc moi j'ai pas eu
l'impression de faire un scénario dans
mon coin et dire on l'a fait aux faisans
[Musique]
ça s'est fait vraiment aussi en
discutant beaucoup à coralliens parce
qu'au départ je change et à des choses
plus plasticienne plus avec de
l'aquarelle d encre et finalement lui il
a donné un ton un peu plus léger un peu
plus humoristique un anneau finalement
j'ai adopté un travail qui ressemble
plus à du croquis réaliste
expressionniste ces deux artistes
présenteront la troisième population à
bd boum ce week-end